Narrator: The show that
revolutionized business is back.
In eight years,
with over $87 million invested
in the Tank thus far,
Shark Tank businesses
have generated
hundreds of
millions in sales...
Even you couldn't have predicted
this kind of breakout success.
No, but it's on all of us what
a platform "Shark Tank" is.
...employed thousands...
Woman:
You're creating great jobs
for the people
in the state of Maine.
So keep them coming.
... and changed how America
does business.
President Obama: We have a lot
of brain power here.
We even got a few Sharks.
"Shark Tank"'s become
an American phenomenon,
and the support of the president
just goes to show you
that the American dream
is alive and well.
Narrator:
From their humble beginnings,
the Sharks are all self‐made
and understand what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing.
And now they're here to help
other entrepreneurs
realize their dreams.
I resonate with this, and I want
to be a part of this.
You are gonna succeed.
There is no doubt in my mind.
You guys are the American dream
come true.
You are why I do this show.
Narrator: Together they've
created monster successes...
I'll make you a millionaire
within a year.
Man: Lori helped me get
into every Bed Bath & Beyond,
and now we've topped $85 million
in sales.
Narrator: ... and impacted
the world for the better.
Woman #2: We were able to take
100 kids off the streets.
We chased our dreams, and now
we're seeing them come true.
[ Cheering ]
Narrator: And tonight it all
begins again...
Steeler Nation, baby!
Narrator: ...making business
entertaining...
‐Robert, you love me, don't you?
‐I do love you!
‐Yes! Whoo!
‐... inspirational...
Woman #3: [ Crying ]
I was brave and vulnerable,
and it was scary.
Today I'm proud of myself.
Narrator: ... and relevant.
You've got an opportunity
to tell this story
to 8 million to
10 million Americans.
The most valuable airtime
in the world.
Narrator: The power
of "Shark Tank" is back.
Whoo!
Woman #4: This has been a long
road and a lot of hard work,
and it's all coming true.
I know I can do this.
Some businesses are born
in hell,
and this is one of them.
‐Ohh!
[ Crying ] It's just hard to go
through all of this.
Man: Sorry, baby.
Hey, this is just the beginning.
Narrator: And tonight,
for the first time ever,
six Sharks circle the tank.
To going six deep.
And it all begins now.
It's not for the meek.
It's not for the weak.
‐You did it!
‐Whoo!
We got a deal!
Man: 5, 4, 3, 2...
Pull door!
Narrator: First into the tank
is an innovative new technology
to enhance the flavor
of a favorite beverage.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Phil Petracca.
And I'm David McDonald.
We are the founders of Fizzics
from Newark, New Jersey.
We're seeking
a $500,000 investment
for 4% equity
in our company.
Wow.
Fizzics is changing the way
people are drinking beer
at home and on the go.
Beer is pretty awesome,
and we all know that beer
tastes best fresh from the tap.
After all,
that's how the brewers
intended their beers
to taste.
But in order to reach
the masses,
beer is sold in cans
and bottles worldwide.
And unfortunately
for us beer lovers,
it just doesn't taste as good
as it does fresh from the tap.
But drab beer is a thing
of the past with Fizzics ‐‐
the world's first and only
portable draft‐beer system
that delivers an awesome...
Better‐than‐tap...
...experience from any can
or bottle.
Simply place any size can
or any size bottle...
Oh, you put a can in there?
...even up to
a 64‐ounce growler
into the system and insert
the feed tube.
Pull the tap handle forward,
and the system will begin
to pour the beer
under pressure at a controlled
rate with no gas,
no chemicals,
and no replaceable cartridges.
And then when you push
the handle
in the backwards position,
behold, the magic of science.
Utilizing sound waves,
we perfect the density,
stability, and texture
of the foam,
enhancing the aroma and flavor
of an authentic draft beer.
‐What?!
‐Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Who's ready to enjoy the great
taste of a Fizzics beer?
‐Bring it!
‐Because after all...
Both:
... tasting is believing!
Cheers.
‐Cheers.
‐Cheers, Sharks.
‐Let's try it.
‐Bring it.
‐Thank you.
So, we've selected some beers
for you.
We'll be serving you a hand pour
and a Fizzics pour,
so you can do a side‐by‐side
comparison
and taste the difference.
Interesting.
For you, we have a classic
American lager.
This is the regular one.
This is the regular one,
and then the one with the head
on it is a Fizzics pour.
‐Got it.
‐Bring us a whole lot of them.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Try the little one.
All right, so, I tried
the normal one.
Yo, Sharkies,
to going six deep!
Cheers!
‐Cheers!
Wow.
That was really good.
It's like a dessert.
Delicious.
‐Raspberry.
‐Oh, definitely smoother.
Definitely better.
‐Like night and day.
‐Oh, that's a good beer.
‐Oh, that is good.
‐Isn't that good?
‐Yeah.
‐And that's from a can.
‐This is good.
That's from a can.
The foam is really good.
The foam is
the most critical element
of the beer‐drinking
experience.
Can I get a share of hands,
Sharks?
Who feels that the Fizzics is
better than the other one?
I would say this definitely
advances the flavor.
‐Oh, much better.
‐Night and day.
Night and day. They're like
two different beers.
Herjavec:
Let me try the dark one.
We always say tasting
is believing.
‐Believe me, I was...
‐Hands down.
...very skeptical
when I saw this.
‐Right.
‐Yeah, me too.
O'Leary: So you've
achieved something.
Now, I've looked at
the valuation, and I say,
"Are you guys out of
your freaking minds?"
Well, Kevin, we just started
shipping product
eight months ago.
[ Groans ]
And we've done $3.2 million
in sales.
‐Good for you. Wow.
‐Okay.
‐Not bad. Not bad.
‐You just started shipping.
‐How have you been selling them?
‐How much does that cost?
This retails for $199.
And what does it cost you
to make?
$35.88.
‐Oh, wow. Good for you.
‐Good mark‐up.
‐Really?
‐Yeah.
So, we launched
a crowd‐sourcing campaign.
Which one?
Which platform?
Indiegogo.
Our initial goal
was $50,000.
We did about $250,000
in our campaign.
‐Wow.
‐David and I quit our jobs
the next day,
and we've been running
ever since.
KH: Wow.
Tell us exactly how it works.
What's the technology
in there?
‐Sure.
‐Wow.
David and I
are technologists.
We've commercialized technology
our whole careers.
And what we found is the head
of the beer
is the most critical element of
the beer‐drinking experience.
And what we've discovered is
if we're able to get
the density tightly,
densely packed,
uniform bubbles,
we can trick the brain
to say, "This is smooth.
This is creamy."
So we utilize sound waves.
David and I have developed
an oscillating sound pressure
wave generator.
‐Sound wave?
‐Do you have a patent?
We've applied
for two utility patents
and one international
utility patent.
Your current value that you're
asking right now
is $12.5 million.
‐Correct.
‐Wow.
‐And we came in with a very
conservative valuation
because we're here
to get a deal.
‐Very conservative.
‐We're here to get a deal.
‐Yes.
‐[ Chuckles ]
It's $1.3 multiple
of this year's revenue.
How? You're gonna do $3 million
this year.
No, we've already done
$3.2 million.
This year we're gonna do
$9 million.
So we're already
cash‐flow positive.
We just turned a profit
of $220,000.
Herjavec:
I've heard enough.
You're asking for $500,000
for 4%.
I think you're here
to negotiate.
I'll give you the $500,000
for 8%.
Robert, thank you so much
for your offer.
We believe it's way
below market.
This is part of our Series "A"
round ‐‐ have a lead‐in ‐‐
What was the Series "A" round
struck at?
$2 million.
We already have a lead
institutional investor.
So then why are you here?
Thee is a wise man
with great business acumen
that once said...
Yes, I'm here.
..."There are many V. C. s,
but there's only one
Shark Tank."
Well, that's why I made you
the offer at 8%.
You're making my case.
‐Very good.
‐Let me raise the ante.
Are you saying you're not
valuing the Sharks?
Let me raise the ante.
I don't ‐‐
I don't disagree
with Robert.
The value of a Shark
is huge,
but there are Sharks
and then there's Mr. Wonderful.
Who's really not a Shark.
Because this falls
right into my...
Who's a guppy.
... right into my wine and food
business in a huge way.
I already have all
your customers.
I've got hundreds
of thousands of people
who buy direct from me.
They will trust me,
as they do in the wine business.
Nobody sells wine like I do.
So I will give you
the same offer ‐‐
$500,000 for 8%.
I like this deal a lot.
I can move a lot of units ‐‐
a lot.
What are your biggest
challenges?
Philip:
This is a challenge, Mark.
The great thing
about our company
is we're creating
a category.
The challenge with our company
is we're creating a category.
‐Right.
‐Mark, do you have an offer?
Cuban: I'm trying to find out,
you know,
if it seems too good to be true.
Corcoran: It's always too good
to be true.
I'm wildly enthusiastic
about the product,
but I'm not wildly enthusiastic
about you.
I feel like you're too slick.
You have every answer.
Narrator: All six Sharks
are still in.
David and Philip have two offers
on the table
for their draft‐beer
system Fizzics,
but Barbara is skeptical
about the entrepreneurs.
I'm wildly enthusiastic
about the product,
but I'm not wildly enthusiastic
about you.
I feel like you're too slick.
You have every answer.
And my gut is ringing,
"There's got to be
something wrong."
You're too slick for me.
I don't trust you.
So I'm out.
Phil, the main reason that
I started to do this show
and love this program is all the
people that really need help.
You don't need any money.
You're cash flow positive.
Why are you here?
‐We need to scale.
There are some retailers
that we want to go into
that we currently can't 'cause
we have channel conflict.
So, what I want to show ‐‐
‐Give me an example of that.
‐What I want to show you all...
‐Give me an example.
...is what we're anticipating
and what we're investing in.
You didn't even get
to your slides yet?
[ Laughter ]
Philip: This is our
next‐generation product.
Phil, Phil, I'm just gonna
let everybody ‐‐
Wait, wait, wait,
I want to see.
‐Phil, Phil, Phil, Phil,
Phil, Phil, Phil!
‐This is our next‐generation ‐‐
‐Yes, sir?
‐I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐Why'd you do that?
‐Just let him go, Phil.
‐Go, Phil.
‐I'm not out.
‐Wait, Phil. Phil.
‐I'm still in, Phil.
He's out.
You got five more to go.
‐I'm interested.
‐We worked really hard
to be here.
Can you please show me
what that is?
And we have a lot to share. And
that's what we're trying to do.
So, this is Waytop.
We're gonna launch this.
This is a more cost‐effective
price point.
It's much smaller.
‐How is that different, though?
‐What's the difference?
This one would only do a can
and up to a 12‐ounce bottle.
Phil, the great thing for you
is I have QVC
and TV sales because you need to
get out there ‐‐ education.
You need people
to know what it is.
‐Absolutely.
‐So it's free advertising.
So I am also going to give you
$500,000 for 8%.
Ooh, everybody seems stuck
at that 8%.
Everybody's at 8%.
Phil, just so you know,
this is a fact ‐‐
the number‐one provider of wine
on QVC is me.
Where do you want to go that you
can't get to right now?
Yeah, we want to be in Bed Bath
& Beyond with that product.
Whoa! That's where I have
a huge relationship.
I think at $99 at Bed Bath
& Beyond, they have ‐‐
Cuban: Okay,
that makes more sense.
You know I have
a great relationship
with Bed Bath & Beyond.
Hello, Phil?
What about in commercial ‐‐
in restaurants and bars?
‐Phil, Phil, Phil?
‐Tabletop type thing.
‐Phil?
‐What are you doing there?
So, we've had
some discussions.
Can it withstand
commercial abuse, right?
‐Yes.
‐Phil, you have three offers.
What are you gonna do,
Mark?
Okay, so, I'm gonna make
an offer.
And I'll even open up to Lori
to come in on my offer.
So I'll offer you $800,000
for 10%.
That valuation is higher
than the $500,000 for 8%,
but it gives you more cash
so you can go to work faster,
and you have
either one or two Sharks.
I would like to make a counter
to Mark and Lori.
I like the deal.
All right, I think we would be
great partners.
This is our
Series "A" round.
If you wanted to take
the whole Series "A,"
we're looking
to raise $2 million
at a $10 million
pre‐money valuation.
Yeah, right.
So that's 16%?
Yes. 16.67%.
‐Well, I want to compete ‐‐
‐Okay, I'll do that deal.
‐Done.
‐Oh, my God!
‐Deal!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Put it up here, baby.
‐It's really fabulous.
‐Put it up here.
‐Get up here.
‐I'm not a beer drinker.
‐You are now, baby!
‐And you just converted me.
‐You are now!
‐I am now.
‐You are now.
Whoo! [ Laughs ]
Yeah!
We did it!
We risked it all ‐‐
left great jobs.
This is the American dream.
I'm just so full of emotion
right now.
[ Voice breaking ]
This is awesome.
[ Cries ]
It's okay.
Narrator: In Season 7,
Shaan Patel secured a deal
with Mark Cuban for his SAT
prep course 2400 Expert.
I'll offer you the 250k
for 20%.
All right,
I take your offer, Mark.
Done.
Narrator: Let's see
what he's up to now.
Patel: Since making my deal
with Mark,
we changed the name
from 2400 Expert
to Prep Expert because the SAT
went from the 2400 scale
back to the 1600 scale.
Welcome, everyone.
Today I'm teaching
a special program
to underserved youth in
my community of Las Vegas.
So, who's ready to do a problem?
They are high‐achieving
but simply lack the resources
to get great standardized
test scores.
Give a big round of applause
for Mark Cuban!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Cuban:
Shaan has invited me out
to this program that he's doing
with his community,
and I thought it would be great
to come out here
and get the kids fired up
and have a good time.
It really doesn't matter
where you start.
Anything is possible.
When I come out and talk
to these kids,
I see in their eyes they want to
accomplish things in their life.
And if I can just give them
a little bit of motivation,
that's a huge win.
The key is finding something
you really like to do
and then being great at it.
Patel: The year before
"Shark Tank,"
I did just $600,000 in sales.
Just six months
after making my deal,
I've done $4 million in sales.
Prep Expert is on track
to become one of
the largest test‐prep providers
in the nation.
Thank you, everybody.
My goal as a Shark
is to go out there
and help as many kids as I can
to accomplish their dreams
by helping them start
businesses.
That's what "Shark Tank"
is all about.
That's what the American dream
Patel: My parents came to
this country with nothing,
and they built their own
American dream.
When my dad looks at me now,
I can tell I'm his American
dream come true.
Narrator:
Next up is a way to send
a little love and comfort
to your loved ones.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Marti Wymer.
And I'm Scott Gustafson.
Our company is
Spoonful of Comfort.
And we are seeking $400,000
in growth capital
in exchange for 10%
of our business.
When someone you love
is sick or hurting,
whether it's family
or friend,
it's human nature
to want to be there,
do something
to help them feel better.
Unfortunately,
in today's world,
when loved ones
often live far away,
many of us feel helpless.
Traditionally,
the only options
have been to send flowers,
fruit, or candy.
However, we all know that the
best cure for what ails you
is the comfort of good,
old‐fashioned chicken soup.
But getting that soup
all the way
across the country
always ‐‐ isn't always easy.
Here comes Spoonful of Comfort
to the rescue.
A care package ordered
from our website
delivers a ready‐to‐go meal
right to the doorstep.
Each gift includes
a generous family‐sized jar
of hand‐crafted soup,
a half dozen bakery rolls
and cookies
all beautifully packaged
and guaranteed to make them
and you feel better.
All of this at a cost
equal to or less
than a bouquet of flowers.
So when you
can't mail a hug,
Spoonful of Comfort
is the next best thing.
So, who wants a taste of this
growing gourmet soup business?
‐I do.
‐I love soup.
‐I hope you're hungry!
‐All right, we've got samples.
Bring it on.
You know, there are six Sharks
up here now.
Marti: Yeah.
Yeah, we do.
I hope you have enough
for six.
Scott: We did actually
get six, so...
Nervous, shaky hands
to hand you soup.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Got it?
‐Oh, there's two kinds of soup.
‐Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh, wow.
Thank you, sir.
I appreciate it.
Greiner:
I tried the tomato first,
and it's excellent.
‐Don't spill it.
‐It's good.
Wow, you know, both of these
soups are great.
‐This is good.
‐Mmm!
‐It's delicious.
How much do you sell
a package for,
and what's your cost on it?
Marti: We sell a package
for $69.99.
‐With two soups?
‐$69.99?!
‐Oh, that's a lot of soup.
‐Wait a minute.
However, that feeds a family.
‐Oh, there you go. Okay.
‐So, you get that jar.
Oh, there you go.
Marti:
So, you get this jar,
a half dozen rolls in this box,
six cookies in this box.
What does it cost to ship?
$69.99 ‐‐ Is that inclusive
of shipping?
‐Right.
‐Or is shipping added on top?
Marti: So, no, it does not.
So, we have a standard shipping
of $14.99.
‐Ouch!
‐That's actually
a really good ‐‐
Hang on.
I can buy soup for somebody
or put them through college.
My choice.
‐[ Chuckles ]
So, tell us a little bit about
the business. Tell us more.
Well, the idea for the business
came about October of 2007
when I got that
dreaded phone call.
[ Voice breaking ] My
mother had been diagnosed
with lung cancer,
and the worst part
about hearing the news
is she was living
thousands of miles away.
And I just felt helpless
being so far away.
So I jumped online
to send her something,
and tons of options,
like we said ‐‐
flowers, candy, fruit ‐‐
but, like, nothing just
felt appropriate
for that situation.
And so I immediately thought
of chicken soup.
It's what she,
like many mothers,
used to make
to comfort me.
But I couldn't find
any to send.
So, tragically, I lost her
just six weeks later.
Out of that tragedy,
this idea for Spoonful
of Comfort came about,
and so I thought,
"What better way to honor her
than to help other people
in the same situation?"
Scott, how did you get involved
with the business?
I came out of
business school
and went to work for a big
pharmaceutical company.
Steve, her husband, was
our Vice President of Sales.
How much did you put in?
So, I ‐‐ Initially,
I put in $500,000.
‐Wow.
‐$500,000!
KH: How much do
you own of this business?
‐60%.
‐He said "initially."
Where are you at totally
in your commitment of cash
to this business?
So, I have loaned in another
approximately $800,000.
$1.3 million?
Start at the beginning.
‐I'll start back a few years.
‐Make it good.
It's a lot of money.
When we launched this,
we partnered with a group
that was a national ‐‐
It was a national
daily deal site.
Okay, so you're giving away
the product for less.
So, what we did was we got
into an arrangement with them,
and the popularity of our deal
just took off.
‐Uh‐oh.
‐But you made no money.
So you were losing money
on every deal.
‐Yes.
‐And you were funding it.
And we were calling it the cost
of customer acquisition.
What does it cost you to acquire
the incremental customer now?
Forget about the coupon stuff.
‐Sure.
‐$18.
O'Leary: What price were you
selling it for?
‐For $35.
‐Ooh.
‐And what's your cost?
‐So all of your margin was gone.
‐Yeah.
‐And our costs are $31.
Did the customers
ever order again?
That was the problem.
‐[ Laughs ]
What are your sales?
The most recent 12 months,
we're at $1.08 million.
Okay, that's not horrible.
Corcoran: Here's what I think
is an Achilles heel
in your operation ‐‐
When I send that out
and someone is sick,
I want them getting it then.
‐Sure.
I don't want them receiving it
two, three days hence.
‐Yeah.
Have you not had any issue
with that?
O'Leary:
How much does that cost?
Overnight, what does that cost?
$39.99.
I believe that this is a
business that's going to fail.
The business isn't fancy enough
to support everything
you're doing.
The idea that you put
$1.3 million‐plus
into this business
blows my mind.
Too complicated.
It's nutty.
It'll never, never work.
I want to be a Kevin on this one
and tell you to go out
in the back and shoot it.
I'm out.
And I suggest you go out, too.
I don't think it's a
take‐it‐out‐behind‐the‐barn
and‐shoot‐it, right?
You're not
in the food business.
You're not in the comfort
business.
You're in the marketing
But to be in
the marketing business,
you have to be good
at marketing.
You're trying to be dependent
on us to fix that for you,
and to me, that's a bad
combination.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
John:
I like this actual concept.
The biggest challenge
I'm having with it
is you have to find people
when they have a cold,
and I just don't see it growing
out of that at the moment,
especially with
a very high valuation.
So unfortunately, I'm out.
Really liked the tomato soup,
but I don't like this model.
It's a convenience.
It's cute.
The rolls, the cookies ‐‐
They're all good.
There's nothing wrong with it.
But to me, for this
to become really big,
I don't see that happening.
I see it maybe being something
that can sustain the two of you,
but as an investor,
I couldn't see me getting
my money out of this.
So for that reason, I'm out.
‐Okay, thank you.
‐Thank you.
I like the business.
I mean, it's a great idea.
Nobody loves soup
more than I do.
[ Chuckles ]
Herjavec:
But you know, you've been doing
it for five years now.
You haven't figured out
the kinks.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thanks.
O'Leary: Today is your lucky day
because there's six Sharks.
So you're not dead yet.
Every Shark here have,
over the years,
invested in businesses that have
to acquire customers
and ship food goods to them.
‐Yep.
‐Yes.
O'Leary: And what we've learned
over time
is that the customer acquisition
cost is the whole deal.
‐Right.
‐Whole deal.
Your acquisition costs,
you said earlier, was $18.
Right.
So basically, you have to give
up 40% of your margin,
but it still works.
It's just that
it's a long grind.
I don't know how to help you
reduce your customer
acquisition costs.
I'm out.
We thank you for taking
the time with us.
‐Thank you.
‐Great. Thanks, guys.
Good luck.
‐Thank you.
Thanks, guys. Thank you.
‐Good luck.
Marti: [ Voice breaking ] Even
though we didn't get a deal,
I know that my mom
would be proud.
You know, when you're trying
to build this legacy
in the name of your mother,
I just want to make it work.
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a way
to show off your personality
with every step you take.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks, my name
is Justin Kittredge
from Boston, Massachusetts.
I am founder and CEO of ISlide.
Today I'm seeking $500,000
in exchange for 5% equity
of my company.
ISlide is the only premium
customizable slide
in the industry.
Our motto is,
"Stand in what you stand for,"
'cause our product is an
extension of self‐expression.
We work with teens, brands,
corporations,
and even individuals.
Because of our amazing comfort
and personalization,
high school, college,
and pro teams
of all sports all buy from us.
Celebrities like LeBron James,
Justin Bieber, D. J. Khaled,
and even Madonna
are all rocking ISlides.
And if that's not good enough,
how about the best wide receiver
in the NFL,
Antonio Brown of
the Pittsburgh Steelers?
‐Go, Steelers.
‐Don't believe me?
Ask him yourself one day.
So, Sharks, it's taken me
three years to get here.
ISlide is the only company
in the world
that allows you to stand in
what you stand for.
I'd like to pass out
some personalized gifts.
Thank you, Justin.
‐You're welcome.
‐Which ones are for Lori?
I have to hand them to her.
O'Leary: Thank you, Justin.
Right here.
‐You're welcome.
‐Thank you.
Corcoran: Thank you, Justin.
Greiner:
Oh, look what I got.
‐Oh, cool.
‐It is Queen.
‐This is Cash Flow.
‐Thank you, sir.
‐You got it.
‐Cash Flow. Very nice.
Car racing. Very nice.
‐Oh, little Mavi Slides.
‐All right!
Corcoran:
I really like yours.
Barbara, I like the color
of yours.
John: That's neat.
But it's got my name on it,
so you can't have it.
Greiner:
Those are cute.
This does warm my heart,
I must say.
‐I would hope so.
‐[ Chuckles ]
I wear flip‐flops
almost every day
when I don't have
to wear a suit.
These are the most comfortable
ones I've had in a long time.
Awesome.
O'Leary: I want to understand
your business model
because you're valuing
this company at ‐‐
I can give you $500,000 at 5%.
That's a $10 million valuation.
Yes.
So I'm gonna make the assumption
you've got sales.
So why don't you jump
right into it?
And before you answer that,
did you work at Reebok?
‐I was.
‐That's why you're up in Boston?
‐Yes.
‐Okay.
That makes you
even more credible,
but can you tell us what
your sales are gonna be?
Sure. No problem.
So, we've been in business
for just under three years.
We've done $1.5 million
in sales.
So, I got to tell you
right now ‐‐
Warning, Red Leader, warning ‐‐
because that is
10 times revenue.
That's a really big problem.
But, Justin,
how do you sell them?
O'Leary: And I'm gonna make
a prediction, Justin ‐‐
You are not gonna get
a $10 million valuation
for this commodity.
Could we, perhaps,
understand a little more?
How do you sell them?
‐Absolutely.
So, we have four
distribution channels.
The first one is individuals.
So anyone can come on our site,
individually want ‐‐
‐One at a time.
‐And what do you sell them for?
‐$50.
‐And you'll customize?
‐Justin, can I design it
for myself,
pick the color, the flower
on it, et cetera?
‐100%.
‐Exactly.
‐Yeah, exactly.
‐How long?
‐And you wait how long
to get it?
‐We'll ship it under a week.
‐Nice.
‐Okay, how much does it cost
you to make a ship?
About $15.
The customer pays
for the shipping?
And what percentage of
your sales are that way?
‐That's pretty good.
‐About 15%.
‐Oh, small.
‐Yeah. 15%.
Where's the bulk
of your sales?
With team and drop‐ship.
When you say "drop‐ship,"
what do you mean by that?
Who are you drop‐shipping to?
Our biggest partner
in our drop‐ship model
is with D. J. Khaled.
He does all these different
sayings that he comes up with.
We put them on the Slides.
He sells them.
Every day we get orders
from him,
and we fulfill them
and direct‐ship
right to the customer.
Got it.
We thought he was gonna do
about 20 to 30 pairs
in the first week or two.
He did over 800
in the first day.
John: But you're using
your valuation
because of an influencer, right?
D. J. Khaled is one part
of our business.
We have multiple pieces
of our business
that are only increasing
every day.
O'Leary: Including all your
costs and your own salary,
what do you bring pre‐tax?
About $75,000 net profit.
O'Leary: Yikes.
This is ridiculous!
How do you get to $10 million?
When we do $2.7 million in sales
for the next 12 months,
it's really just over
three times revenue multiple,
which in our industry,
is pretty fair.
No, no, no, but your profit ‐‐
your profit multiple is 30x
on a shoe company.
But not even a shoe company.
Kind of a promo company.
Justin, how did you get
to a $10 million valuation?
Narrator:
All six Sharks are in,
but they question
the high valuation
that Justin has placed
on his customizable
slide company ISlide.
Justin, how did you get
to a $10 million valuation?
I'm really struggling with
the $10 million valuation.
‐Who is that guy?
‐Who's that?
‐There's a guy behind you.
‐Yo, Justin!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐You started without me.
Sorry, buddy.
How you doing?
What's up, Steeler Nation?!
Antonio Brown!
‐What's happening?
‐How you guys doing?
How are your slides?
‐Boomin'.
‐Boomin'!
The L. A. traffic got me
a little slow,
but I'm excited
to be here today.
You left your guy
hanging, huh?
So, as I mentioned
in the opening pitch,
the best wide receiver
in the NFL, Antonio Brown ‐‐
he made it, and, listen,
Antonio's been a friend
for a while.
I mean, he can tell you
a little bit about,
you know,
why he loves ISlide.
Yes.
One reason I love ISlide ‐‐
because you could customize it
to your motivation.
So I put "Boomin'" on my Slides.
But you could make
your slides custom
to what your belief is
or whatever drives you.
Antonio, are you selling them
from your site?
I have. I have sold 400 slippers
in 24 hours.
‐Wow.
‐Yeah.
John: I believe that it's really
good for Antonio.
That's why I'm attracted
to this.
But why does this make you
worth $10 million?
He's worth $10 million.
Why are you worth $10 million?
I know the valuation, you know,
is coming up a lot.
‐Coming up a lot?
‐No, I get it.
But, you know,
you've once said
that you've seen a future trend
is mass customization
an individual scale, right?
Greiner: Personalization
is great and super‐popular.
So you grabbed onto that,
and you're running.
The problem for me is,
besides that you do have
a crazy valuation,
is that there's nothing
to prevent anybody else
from doing this.
For that reason, I'm out.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Justin, I think ‐‐
Antonio sold a lot of ISlides,
so, power to you.
But you want to build
a shoe company.
‐100%.
‐To get to that,
you got to start doing the
mass‐appeal type of licenses.
I've negotiated those ‐‐
Disney, DreamWorks licenses ‐‐
once‐in‐a‐lifetime
kind of deals.
I'll give you the $500,000.
I'll give it to you for 20%.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Wow.
You mind if I hear out
the rest of the Sharks?
Well, I'll help out here.
I'm out.
I appreciate that.
Let me just tell you about me
for one minute.
‐I don't need to.
‐I don't need to hear about you.
‐Does anybody else?
‐You know what,
there's talking time...
I know enough about you.
... and then
there's selling time
and then there's
closing time.
I would take that deal
in two seconds.
You're on the 1‐yard line.
You're on the 1 yard line.
Justin, you're asking us to pay
today for tomorrow's value.
It's just nutsy.
You're too optimistic.
I'm out.
I understand.
Thank you.
In 2004 ‐‐
‐Stop selling.
‐Wait, wait, wait, wait.
‐In 20‐‐
O'Leary: It would be useful
for you to know
if anybody else is interested.
So, Daymond,
are you still in?
‐I'm still in.
‐I understand.
‐Mark, are you still in?
‐In 2004, I got laid off from ‐‐
‐Here we go.
‐I got laid off from Reebok.
I thought it was the most
devastating day of my life.
I thought I was gonna be there
for my entire life,
not even a question.
It was absolutely devastating.
From that moment on,
I knew I want to start
my own business.
I knew I was never gonna put
myself at risk.
We're gonna make it.
There's no question about it.
Daymond, in six months, we went
from concept to market ‐‐
opening up molds, getting
inventory, wear‐testing,
everything.
We're able to have guys
like this who believe in it,
who are the most elite athletes
in the world.
Justin, I respect
what you've accomplished.
I do. The customization,
the fact that you're hustling.
You're lining up people
to grow the business.
You've got great reps like
Antonio boomin' it out, right?
But it's not a business for me.
It's not investable for me.
So I'm out.
John:
This valuation here ‐‐
You're worth no more
than $500,000,
and you're out of your mind
for not taking his offer.
And just for that reason,
I'm out.
And now that offer's
gonna cost you more.
You're crazy. 25 times cash flow
for a tchotchke company.
Are you out of your mind?
‐How did you get 25 times?
You can buy these in China.
He's only gonna make $100,000
next year after tax.
And they'll give you
all you want.
You're paying $2.5 million.
Are you out of your mind?
‐[ Laughs ]
O'Leary: Robert, I can't watch
you kill money that way.
Children are gonna watch this.
You know, Kevin,
that's the beauty ‐‐
They're gonna watch you
kill money.
That's the beauty
of the show.
You're murdering money
in front of children.
And so, Robert, I know
you're not countering,
but I'm gonna counter you anyway
at $500,000 for 10%.
If there's any way
you would do it,
I would do a deal right now.
‐That's insane.
No. No way. Justin, I was ‐‐
I was giving you
a future value because of
your operation expertise.
Robert, you were insane
for that valuation.
‐That's insane.
‐It's optimistic.
$500,000, 20%.
I'm ‐‐ I'm done at that number.
Final offer, Justin.
Um...
I just can't thank you enough
for the offer, Robert.
I can't believe
I'm watching this.
I cannot, and I'm truly sorry.
[ Laughs ]
But I do want to say
thank you very much.
But I'm gonna have to decline.
Remember the cartoon
where the guy turns into,
like ‐‐ to
the all‐day sucker?
‐I think you're making
a mistake.
‐That's Robert right now.
You don't know the stuff
you don't know.
But good luck.
Cuban: Hey, he's willing
to grind it out.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Good luck.
Corcoran:
Thanks for the shoes.
‐Thank you, man.
‐Good to see you again, Antonio.
By the way, you just witnessed
insanity in the Tank.
I'll take the $500,000.
[ Laughter ]
Justin: I can't believe
I turned down $500,000,
but at the same time,
I till left money on the table
but I didn't leave them down.
I just ‐‐ All I go to right now
is how hard...
[ Sighs ]
I haven't cried in like
[bleep] 10 years.
[Bleep]
My name is Trisha Prabhu.
I'm 16 years old, and I'm from
Naperville, Illinois.
I'm an ambitious person,
and I love aiming
for number one.
I started coding
when I was 10 years old.
Very quickly, I learned
that it was something
I was really passionate about.
I've been invited
to the White House.
I was named a Google Science
Fair Global Finalist.
My work has been recognized
by M. I. T.,
and I've even given
three T. E. D. talks.
Today we are going to be
learning about variables.
I wanted to give back
to my community
and inspire young girls,
so I started teaching
Girls Who Code classes.
I definitely believe in the
concept of technology for good.
My business centers around
one of the biggest problems
facing kids and teens today,
and I'm using technology
to solve an issue
that many people believe
technology has created.
It's been a very tough road.
As a 16‐year‐old,
there are a lot of skeptics
that don't take me seriously,
that don't take
my product seriously.
A lot of people don't see me
as the Silicon Valley
tech stereotype.
But that means I need
to break that barrier.
That's something that I'm proud
to be doing.
I truly believe that
this business is my future,
and with the Sharks, we can see
that future become a reality.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Trisha Prabhu,
and I'm from Naperville,
Illinois.
I'm the creator of ReThink,
and today I'm here
seeking $100,000
in exchange for a 20%
equity stake in ReThink.
Now, we all know the Tank
has seen
its share of harsh comments.
No!
"You're a cockroach."
So true sometimes.
"You're a zero, not a hero.
You're not an entrepreneur.
You're a want‐trepreneur."
And, of course,
"You're dead to me."
Now, if you think
the Tank is bad,
the Internet is so much worse.
Cyber bullies hide
behind their screens
and use mean, tormenting,
and humiliating words every day
to bully others.
It's a silent pandemic
that affects millions.
But I'm determined to stop this.
ReThink stops cyber bullying
by stopping hurtful messages
before the damage is done.
If an adolescent tries to post
something offensive
on social media
or text someone a cruel message,
my ReThink app
is able to detect
that that message is offensive
and then provide the adolescent
a second chance to
reconsider their decision.
Here's how it works.
This is an example
of a typical conversation
between two classmates.
Ooh!
Looks like Joey wants to ask
Erica to the homecoming dance.
‐Ooh.
‐Let's see what she says.
‐[ Laughing ] Oh, gosh.
‐Ouch!
There's no need to say
something like that.
Luckily, with my app,
Erica can rethink her decision.
Much better.
By taking an extra second to
pause, review, and rethink,
Erica ultimately makes
the better decision.
And will you look at that?
They both walk away
with no hard feelings.
I don't think
he's gonna stop asking.
[ Chuckles ]
ReThink was able to stop
the damage before it was done.
In this era of
digital parenting,
ReThink also provides parents
an opportunity
to help shape
their child's behavior
by encouraging positive decision
making both online and offline.
Do you want to sit back and
wonder at what could have been?
Or do you want to stand up,
speak out,
and join me to stop
cyber bullying forever?
Thank you.
So, Erica, she gets that pop‐up
message comes up...
‐Correct.
‐ReThink.
What if she just hits, "OK"?
Can she still send it?
‐Absolutely.
So, we're not taking away
anyone's right
to express any of their feelings
or opinions.
They can still post that message
if they like.
So you're simply giving them
that extra time to rethink.
But did Erica have to sign up
for your app?
Trisha: So, that's a really
great question.
Why would cyber bullies
download ReThink?
That's why we target two main
groups ‐‐ educators and parents.
Those are the people that are
looking right now
for solutions to cyber bullying.
I'm just very curious why
you would think of this
in the first place.
Tell us a little bit about
your own background.
Well, I'm actually a 16‐year‐old
high‐school junior.
And when I was 13 years old,
I actually came home from school
one day to read online
about an 11‐year‐old girl
who lost her life
to cyber bullying.
She had been cyber‐bullied
for over a year and a half,
and it just ‐‐
it really broke my heart
to think that someone younger
than myself
had suffered endlessly
because of an issue
that didn't have
a better solution.
And immediately, I wanted to be
able to make a difference.
I wanted to use technology
to solve a problem
that technology itself
has created.
I cannot believe you're 16.
‐Yeah, you carry yourself
very well.
‐You're so powerful.
‐Thank you.
‐Trisha, have you sold any?
So, so far, we've garnered
about $52,000
from the We Think ReThink
Educational Program.
Schools everywhere, because of
new state and federal laws,
are required to monitor
and supervise
anti‐cyber‐bullying
education in schools.
So what we do is we actually
provide them curriculum.
We provide them
this ReThink technology
on their school devices.
We provide them
ReThink analytics
on how the technology
is working with students.
We've gotten 128,000 downloads
on both our Google Play Store
and the App Store.
‐Through what period of time?
‐That's nine months.
Herjavec: The amount
of downloads you've had
is very impressive
for nine months.
Thank you.
It's a good idea,
but there's some challenges
to it.
And the challenge to it is
that the user is in control
of the experience.
In other words,
if I'm really a cyber bully,
all I have to do is hit "OK,"
and the message
still goes through.
Trisha: When I first came up
with this idea,
I had the same doubts
that you did.
"What if they just hit 'no'
every time?"
So I ended up conducting
a 1,500‐trial study,
and we find that over 93%
of the time,
when teenagers get
this ReThink alert,
they change their mind.
Cuban: So, let's get the proof
in the pudding, right?
What's your daily active usage?
So, every day,
we have about 80,000 ‐‐
Who wrote all the code for it?
So, I've actually been coding
since I was 10.
‐Wow.
‐Something I love to do.
‐You coded this?
‐Yes.
What a tremendous
entrepreneurial talent.
Thank you.
I think you have a decision
to make.
I think you have to decide
if this is a charity
or if this is a business.
I think what you have to do here
is decide that this is a charity
and try to get money to support
the charity
because it's certainly
a worthy cause
and easy to convince everybody
else to believe in.
But I really think when you want
to start a business
that makes money,
it's got to be something
totally different.
I think you're doing
the right thing, but I'm out.
Thank you so much, Barbara.
So, obviously,
everybody agrees
you're remarkably talented
for 16.
That's fantastic.
‐Thank you.
You're destined to do
something great.
I don't know what it is yet.
You're gonna find out.
But it's not this.
This is not going
to make you rich.
Taking on an investor means you
have a new responsibility.
You have to make them money.
And I am 100% committed
to that.
I have never been afraid
of hard work.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
So, I think
it's a fantastic cause.
You, at 16,
are incredibly talented.
But content‐filtering software's
been around
for a very long time.
‐Sure.
‐This really isn't that unique.
Trying to sell it this way
for people to download this
as an application ‐‐
it's gonna be a struggle.
I don't see it
as a business today.
I'm out.
I wish you all the best of luck.
‐Thank you.
What are you gonna use
the money for?
So, the $100,000 would be used
to hire employees
to start building infrastructure
so that we can roll this out
to the large scale of interest
that we have.
The resources I have ‐‐
‐The large scale of interest?
Like what?
I have 1,200 schools
that are interested
in having this
for the upcoming 2016‐2017
school year,
and T‐Mobile Europe,
the phone carrier,
was interested in actually
implementing this.
I decided I wanted this to be
more than just one carrier
just for one region
of the world.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You had a carrier contact you?
‐I did.
‐And you said no?
Trisha: I turned it down
because at that point,
it was a very early stage.
It was just at the point
when we had launched the app.
We were getting thousands
and thousands of downloads.
I genuinely believe that this
can be something more
than just one carrier,
and I think
that we can get there.
John: All right, so, I think
there is a business here.
I'm not ‐‐
This is not about charity.
I want to be a part of this.
I like the cause.
I like the concept.
I'll give you the $100,000
for 30%.
This happens to be
a passion of mine
because I think
it's super‐important.
I love the kind of woman
that when her feet hit
the ground in the morning,
the competition's like,
"Oh, crap. She's up."
You're that woman.
I'm gonna offer you $100,000.
I'm gonna do it for the 20%.
And I honestly wouldn't
even mind doing it
with another Shark here
because I think the more people
that are involved in it,
the better to get the word out.
Cuban's not out.
Mark's not out.
‐But, Mark, you're still in.
‐Right.
If you want to get this
into as ubiquitous a position
as possible,
working with a carrier is
by far, without any question,
the best way to go.
Absolutely.
The reason for that is
they can put it on a phone
as a default option.
It can come pre‐installed.
They can, then, offer it
to consumers, to parents ‐‐
"This is
a kid‐friendly phone,"
or, "We sell
a kid‐friendly version."
Is that a viable option
to you?
Something that
I would be open to,
and with your guidance,
with your expertise,
I can make those decisions.
John:
What do you got, Mark?
Here's my offer ‐‐
I'll go in with Lori.
You know, we can split it.
All right, so,
Mark is in with Lori.
$100,000 for 20%.
$50,000 from each.
Damon's $100,000 for 30%.
Time to make a decision.
Mark and Lori,
I'm gonna accept your offer.
‐All right, great.
‐Thank you both so much.
Greiner: Great.
Congratulations.
It'll be exciting
to work with you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
‐I'm really glad.
‐Thank you.
This is a passion of mine.
Thank you so much.
We're gonna do
a lot with it.
‐Awesome.
‐A lot with it.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you all so much
for your time.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
Honestly, it's just shock waves
right now.
I can't believe
I just made a deal
with Mark Cuban
and Lori Greiner.
Oh, my God,
I'm so proud of you!
Good job!
Love you so much!
I think that, you know, the
three of us working together ‐‐
I mean, we can make ReThink a
multi‐million‐dollar success,
and I really believe with them
it is possible.